okay let's get into audience questions
for the week some very good ones first
one is about trump voters hey david
why is it that rural and blue collar
as well as older white people seem to
favor donald trump so
yes that is true it's important to
remember that increasingly this group
is not leaning as much towards trump as
they as they once were we looked at
numbers in
i believe it was pennsylvania maybe
wisconsin some other places where
the white vote is not as in favor of
donald trump this year
as it was in 2016 but the final numbers
remain to be seen but yes it's true that
donald trump's strongest demographic
group
remains white folks and older folks
although
older folks overall have abandoned trump
and now favor joe biden but the question
is why it's a good one
and understanding the why is necessary
if democrats don't want to make the same
mistakes as
as they did in 2016. now of course 2016
was rife with
you know james comey's press conferences
about hillary clinton's emails
and foreign meddling you know all these
different factors
but there was a bit of a lack of
understanding from
from hillary clinton and democrats about
how to talk about economic anxiety
now there was racism there's this big
debate over anybody saying economic
anxiety explains trump's win
is ignoring racism no it was both and
for some people it was more one than
more one or the other but there's no
doubt that
over the last 20 30 years of
globalization
as we've seen much manufacturing go
elsewhere and the u.s become more of a
service-based economy
the people disproportionately affected
by that
are folks working in manufacturing jobs
manufacturing jobs are
disproportionately in more rural areas
and midwestern states and in other
places like that
and those who have benefited from the
united states
moving towards being a service economy
have been people
on the coasts in cities tech workers
service workers and others so one
reality is that on
in total you know there was this
neoliberal idea
that in the aggregate the u.s would do
better
the economy would in total be better
there would be more total wealth and
lower
overall prices with this change of
moving manufacturing out and creating
service and
information jobs that happened but it
was overwhelmingly concentrated
in certain parts of the country and not
in others but
politics aside it was also
overwhelmingly concentrated for the one
percent
as we see stagnant wages for large
swaths of americans
and huge income and wealth gains for
the top one percent and even groups
smaller than the top one percent so
for some people they
fell for trump's rhetoric around trade
and the middle class
it was bs populist rhetoric it went
nowhere
but there was a group already
predisposed to favor republicans
in many parts of the country rural older
white
who fell for it and uh it has not gone
particularly well for them now
separately if you look at evangelical
and religious voters
they also are predisposed to vote on
abortion lines
trump claimed to be anti-abortion in
2016. he still claims to hillary clinton
was
in favor of a woman's right to choose so
for some folks it's not actually about
economics
it's as simple as as abortion which
continues to be a
not only a voting issue but the voting
issue for many americans so
there's whenever we want to look into
these questions this is part of what i
spoke about earlier this week
in our interview about the us possibly
as
several countries 331 million people
most countries don't have this many
people and
you have radically different uh
not just ideologies but concerns and
day-to-day life
the day-to-day life of someone who lives
in boston and works at a tech firm
has almost nothing to do with the life
of someone who is a
you know rural ohio factory worker
we speak the same language we're
americans etcetera but
these are very lit different day-to-day
experience both
culturally and even just in the nuts and
bolts logistics of it
and you can't really give one answer to
any question that asks about
such a broad trend in a country of 330
million people